Speaker 1: Okay. A few other things to tell
you about today. Are they the American right?
MAGA movement is continuing with the
just assassination talk. And it started
with the search warrant at Mar a Lago with the
idea that this is the precursor to eventually
assassinating Donald Trump. Of course, completely
absurd. Now they're just generally going into the
assassination of people, but the blame is being
placed on the Biden administration. And that's
how I mean, when your brain rots like this,
it's how you end up with Steve Bannon telling
Marjorie Taylor GREENE during an interview on Real
America's Voice War Room, something like that.
Steve Bannon telling Marjorie Taylor
GREENE. The Biden administration
is trying to assassinate people. Hmm.
Speaker 5: Maybe the same people that have been
swatting me, or apparently you got swatted last
night and I heard it. I heard it was a pretty big
deal. But this is who they are. This matches up
with exactly what Joe Biden showed us last night.
And so, you know, the real question is, are any.
Speaker 3: Of the the Bethesda Bethesda speech,
the Scranton speech, what Gene Pryor
said, the thing about extremism,
if you don't believe in their rule, that you're
an extremist. And what he said, it's all of
a piece. They're trying to have people, their
political opponents assassinated, death by cop.
Speaker 1: Now, there's a couple of
different things here. The swatting is
the idea, I guess, that Bannon is
saying is when someone gets swatted,
which is what happened to Marjorie Taylor. GREENE
The idea is someone calls the police and says,
oh, I'm being held that Marjorie Taylor GREENE
house. The idea, vaguely extrapolated out fully
would be the SWAT team shows up and shoots
Marjorie Taylor GREENE dead, thinking that
Marjorie Taylor GREENE is holding somebody hostage
or something, that that would be sort of the idea.
Now, the waters are not the Biden administration.
And so the idea that the Biden administration
wants to have their political opponents
assassinated seems pretty wacky to extrapolate
from the facts. But if you zoom out a little
bit what is happening here and their fury at
these speeches, Joe Biden's various speeches,
is that the people who are against democracy,
that's them. That's Steve Bannon, Marjorie Taylor
GREENE. When you say Trump really won and should
be the president, that's factually incorrect. And
it is a statement against democracy. Democracy
would be the person who won gets to be the
president. The people who are against democracy
are furious that Biden called out people who are
against democracy. That's fundamentally what's
going on here. The people who have laughed
and nodded along for years, as Trump said,
Lock that person up and lock this person up. And
I really won the election. And we should we should
give the death penalty for drug dealers and make
me the president, even though I didn't win. Now
they are saying Joe Biden is being really mean.
And so, sadly, this entire assassination thing,
as they seem to be getting closer and closer
to rioting again. Right. Because, listen,
if Trump's indicted, they're going to riot. They
are making more and more claims that the left
is actually trying to kill people. So
there's like three or four different
layers to this thing. And of course, when we
think about stochastic terrorism in this country,
it is perpetrated by the right almost exclusively,
remember. Stochastic terrorism is you have an
audience and you go, this is just an example. You
go on every night and you go, They've got to do
something about these Mexican immigrants.
Someone's got to do something about them.
And if there's a 0.001% chance that someone
in the audience is going to take you literally
if there's a thousand people in your audience, it
probably won't happen. If there's 10,000 people in
your audience, it probably won't happen if you've
got a million or 2 million people in your audience
and there's that point zero, you know, whatever
percent chance. And you keep saying every night
we someone's got to take care of these people,
whoever. Now it becomes statistically greater
than 50% that someone in your audience is going
to go and do it. And there's rarely, if ever,
legal liability for the stochastic terrorist. But
that's been the M.O. of the American right now
for a very, very long time. And we started
seeing this with Glenn Beck and others during the
Obama era. I would argue even the Bush era, quite
frankly, I'm trying to think back exactly now. But
there's that and then there's the projection, of
course. They are getting close to another riot.
Mark my words, there will be
violence from these people
if Trump is indicted, which would be a completely
legal process with all of the appropriate legal
I's dotted and t's crossed. And they are now
talking about, oh, it's the left that is about
to be violent again. Not going to happen.
It's going to be these people once again.